i do some work with people in very high
performing
very uh complicated even chaotic type
work you know elite military and these
kinds of people
athletes and for that matter i have
friends who are neurosurgeons who have
very demanding jobs where one small
error can can be catastrophic
they all practice gratitude
it's a it's if ever there was this kind
of secret weapon people talk a lot about
meditation nowadays and you know you
know everybody who's a high performer
meditates that might be true but i i can
say with some degree of certainty that
people who are really high performers
and that by that i mean people who
perform well in lots of domains of their
life but exceptionally well usually in
one or two
they
exercise gratitude they have some
gratitude practice that they bring in
periodically throughout the day or just
even once a day
gratitude you know for many years
gratitude uh was discussed as this thing
about just it was almost like it implied
just be grateful with what you have
but we need to remove the just part of
that statement
it's about
stopping for a moment you could be even
in motion i suppose but stopping for a
moment and shifting your perception and
your attention to the things that
are that you have something that you
value could be a relationship with with
a person or a pet it could be the fact
that you're still alive it could be the
fact that anything anything that you are
appreciative of
what you're doing is you're
moving into interoception you're
shifting your thinking toward what's
contained within your own skin and that
you have at this moment even if it's a
relationship with something that's
outside the skin of your body the
it's a relationship with something that
you have
that stimulates we know that stimulates
the release of serotonin and at a longer
time scale things like oxytocin this
works best if you think about a
relationship to some person or or some
other
i mentioned pet because it doesn't have
to be a human being but in general
that's where it works best
and that shift
provides a number of positive things
first of all
it it does increase it's known to
improve immunity there's no question
that being in those states where
serotonin is released can improve
immunity
there
is a positive effect on other
neurochemical systems and circuits in
the brain
including some spill over to the
dopamine system and that spill over to
the dopamine system then restores our
optimism
and our feeling of what's possible about
what's out there in the world the
dopamine system and the serotonin system
were designed to kind of work back and
forth and kind of a push pull but they
kind of pass the ball back and forth and
that dopamine trigger then makes us
think that there is a future there is
possibility because the the fact that it
is all about anticipation in the sense
of more is it's not necessarily at
appropriate levels a greedy sense of
more so gratitude if you do this
it's again gratitude is not complacency
it's shifting your brain into a mode of
possibility you so it's it's a little
bit
counterintuitive because you think if i
just
focus on what i've already got how is
that focused on on possibility but
that's because it triggers the
activation of these neurochemical
systems that then place our attention on
okay everything is okay internally and
therefore i can focus on the external
right because the internal landscape and
environment is okay because my home is
secure your and here i'm talking about
your biological home i can therefore
focus on what's out there in the world
that i want to pursue and that's
possible
we we are very much like any business or
any household uh in that we need to take
care of our internal real estate first
in order to take care of the external
real estate
now
the the key to this practice and it is
that
the more intense that you feel that the
better and it can take some practice
people don't necessarily get this the
first time they don't get overwhelmed
with a sense of gratitude and you're not
even necessarily looking for a sense of
overwhelm oftentimes you're just going
to do this for 10 seconds one minute
this is a trivial amount of time in the
greater scope of things but its positive
effects are are outscaled with that time
investment and i what i will say is that
i'll mention one other incentive for
gratitude practice there's a
mother nature generally has a reward and
she has a punishment chemical and
there's a molecule that we all make
although we don't release it all the
time called tachycynin it's a peptide
that has been shown in organisms as low
as flies and mice and as high
as humans meaning on the phylogenetic
scale
the
t the release of tachykinin is a
punishment signal that lowers immunity
increases fear and anxiety and can
actually cause a kind of irritable
aggression it is not something that we
want and
what's remarkable is that
gratitude and social connection as well
as physical touch
provided it's positive physical touch
depletes or reduces tachykine and
release
so
it's incredible you know mother nature
put
gave us positive rewards and suppressed
the punishment signals on the dopamine
side there's a if we achieve what we
want if we're regularly giving ourselves
the subjective sense that we're on the
right path by being in action not just
that we're reaching goals but that we're
on the right path and that we're forward
leaning this being center of mass
forward
not only is dopamine release not our
only are the hormones that i described
before given positive
effects
but in addition to that there's a
pathway in the brain involving a brain
structure called the habenula
h-a-b-e-n-u-l-a
which is its job is to trigger
disappointment and depression and this
circuit gets suppressed when we're doing
the right things incidentally the
habenula connects to our pancreas it
controls blood sugar this should make
good sense
if we are doing the right things our
blood sugar regulation this is in wu
science this is actually the paper
published in nature earlier this year
and as well as one in the journal cell
both phenomenal journals not from my
laboratory i should say the work was
done in other laboratories showing that
there are punishment signals that come
out of habenula which can disrupt our
blood sugar and make us feel lousy and
depressed in general when we do the
wrong things and it's all subjective so
when we do the right things we're
rewarded biologically with these
positive chemicals and these depression
circuits are suppressed
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
you